puffin is a software company
specifically what we're building is
tools to help artists market direct a
fan and ultimately sell product direct
to fan distribution has been
commoditized you can for 35 bucks go to
tune core and have the same distribution
as trent reznor marketing though which
is really the third thing that that
traditional music companies you know
have in their arsenal is hard and
getting harder
it's a web-scale thing and you're crazy
not to be leveraging the youtubes and
last FM's and I'm Eames the world and
understanding how all of those things
play into everything that's going on
because you know you want to want to be
where the fans are it's not billed and
they will come everything that we build
is super distributable even you know the
the free track for email widget which a
lot of our artists use and a big moment
for me even though it's really simple
was seeing that free track for email
widget show up on kids blogs you know
hey new metric track come get it and it
wasn't you know here's a link to a to a
you know you send it link it was but
just put your email address here it's
super easy it's good for the band and
then being able to look and go wow this
blog over here is driving more signups
than my own site maybe I should call
that person up now maybe we should do
our next 7-inch release through them
first you know it really obvious stuff
but without the data you know pretty
impossible to get your arms around
we're definitely data nerds we took the
download data from national and put that
with Google Maps and then we're able to
visualize where it came from
for the Dave Byrne Brian Eno record we
also took the sales data the actual
timing of the sales and plotted those on
a map over time which was pretty fun
because eight you mean you just see the
sort of international appeal of it the
moment it was released and you could
also just kind of watch people wake up
in waves across you know from the UK
over to the west coast
we take a percent of revenue of things
that are sold so it's definitely in our
interest to you know work with people
who we think are going to sell but at
the same time we're not we're working
with a bunch of small bands like fan
Farlow is a great example of a band that
is you know not selling at the level of
you know David burner Eminem who we're
working directly with because it's
really interesting we're getting a lot
of interesting data the most interesting
thing is that the small artists actually
have the same behavior as the large
artists in terms of you know conversion
what people are willing to spend that
sort of thing it's just a different
scale right but if you're looking at on
a pure percentage basis what percentage
of people are willing to pay for the top
to your item so the same with a small
band as it is with a large band that's
really good news right it just it means
that the dynamics are the same when
you're looking across you across your
metrics but you know you just have a
smaller fan base
the things I've been telling people are
you know and when artists ask it's super
straightforward at this point you know
collect more email addresses you know
email addresses are going to account for
a large percentage of your of your sales
in sort of a direct and permission
marketing kind of way and then
participate in any other thing where a
fan can express an interest in what
you're doing and you can then
communicate with them whether that's
Facebook or Twitter or MySpace or you
know collecting mobile numbers the
number one peep reason people don't go
to shows because they didn't know about
them right so if you can get your your
if your gonna let your fans express an
interest in you
and then have a way to reach reach back
out to them you know that works if I had
this conversation with Mark Kate's
formally of ground Royal you know
co-manages MGMT where I said mark you
know look what you got going on MGMT has
a hit on the radio which is a huge
blessing people are searching Google
they're coming to MGMT's a website and
then you're sending them off to iTunes
now next time around I hope you have a
hit on the radio because that's the only
way this whole process starts again
right iTunes emails that consumer every
single Tuesday and you have no idea who
the hell they are and you had them you
know not that you shouldn't be selling
through iTunes because of course you
should if people want to buy from itunes
they can but you've got them right on
your site and you're gonna send them
away for someone else to collect the
data and own that customer is craziness